le beaucoup parce que ça rendrait
promettait beaucoup et que ça déborde de
partout et les loups celi est encore sur
un petit nuage
deux jours après une mobilisation
espérée est préparée depuis si longtemps
l'adrénaline est toujours là
[Musique]
le rassemblement d'aujourd'hui ce que
c'est c'est une grande bouffée d'air je
me sors avoir 35 un jour j'aimerais
savoir des petits-enfants du
gouvernement sont en train d'enlever nos
droits humains une oreille je laisse
donc la parole à gré des retours
changement si vous voulez mais au nom ce
changement ils étaient des centaines de
milliers comme greta tony berg à le
réclamer dans les rues vendredi les
dirigeants les ont-ils entendu si on
devait changer le thème jour au
lendemain au québec seulement 7 des
milliers des milliers de certains qui
seraient privés de leur emploi
donc c'est un peu l'étudiant que l'on a
rejeté la chance de faire une transition
de six heures le mans tout parce que
pour atteindre ses cibles de réduction
des ges soit une baisse de 80% d'ici
le québec devra opérer des changements
radicaux notamment en misant sur les
technologies vertes et en réduisant la
demande énergétique
c'est ce que conclut un rapport sur
lesquels doit se baser le gouvernement
le go pour élaborer son plan
d'électrification
mais pour les militants et les experts
il faudra une plus grande volonté et une
cohérence politique
il va falloir prendre des décisions ces
sites de faire une chose et son
contraire comme acheter un pipeline ou
investis dans des capteurs énergétique
puis ensuite allé d'autre part dire
qu'on lutte contre le changement
climatique efficacement on a pu un peu
plus permettre d'aller en deux
directions opposées en plus de revoir le
mode de gouvernance
le ministre de l'environnement au pôle
poids des ministres de l'économie des
finances donc il faut remettre en un
équilibre le gouvernement le goût doit
présenter son plan de lutte contre les
changements climatiques en janvier entre
temps ce comme lille ou devenus des
chiens de garde du climat promettent de
poursuivre la mobilisation
et si jacques andré charbonneau raid au
canada mon frère